bitcoin's on-chain distribution is
becoming more and more decentralized
what exactly does this mean bitcoin has
a very unique advantage it is a
transparent ledger you can go on and
using on-chain metrics you can see all
of the bitcoin addresses and you can see
what is in there in terms of a bitcoin
balance i went last night and i did a
deep dive looking at what is the
centralization or the decentralization
of the bitcoin ownership on chain what i
found was very very interesting first
let's start with the 10 000 bitcoin
balances so these are wallets on chain
that have 10 000 or more bitcoin in it
what you can see is that these peak the
number of wallets that have at least 10
000 bitcoin or more peaked in october of
2018. bitcoin's price was approximately
six thousand five hundred dollars at the
time and it was right before that big
puke down that signaled the bottom of
the 2018 bear market so 10 000 bitcoin
or more the balance
or the number of wallets with 10 000 or
more bitcoin and it peaked in october of
2018. if we go ahead and we look at a
thousand bitcoins so kind of an order of
magnitude smaller what we see here is
that this peaked in february of 2021
earlier this year there are currently
about 2 100 bitcoin addresses that hold
a thousand bitcoin or more which is
similar to where we were throughout all
of 2020 so what you can see is all
through 2020 we're hovering right around
2000 bitcoin addresses with a thousand
bitcoin or more in them then we had this
big run up and then kind of a puke down
and now we are right back around 2100
bitcoin addresses on chain with at least
a thousand bitcoin or more if we go and
we look at a hundred bitcoin all the
bitcoin addresses that have at least 100
bitcoin or more what we can see is that
the all-time high was the peak in
february of 2017 at the beginning of the
real bull market in 2017. and at the
time there was 18 500 bitcoin addresses
with at least 100 bitcoin but today
there's only about 16
100 bitcoin addresses with a hundred
bitcoin or more so what you can see is
ten thousand a thousand or a hundred
bitcoin in the balance of on chain
wallets those have all peaked they've
all hit an all-time high and then been
trending downward there's less and less
whales on chain with these bitcoin
wallet addresses so what if we go and we
look at the opposite end of the spectrum
if we look at 0.01 bitcoin or 0.1
bitcoin as the balance well first here
we have bitcoin addresses with at least
.01 bitcoin in their balance and what we
can see here is that we continue to hit
all-time high after all-time high there
are now
9.3 million bitcoin addresses that hold
at least 0.01 bitcoin or more just over
500
or so if we look at bitcoin addresses
that hold point one bitcoin about five
to six thousand dollars worth of bitcoin
in their balance we can see that
continues to also hit all-time highs you
can see here that there are 3.28
million bitcoin addresses that have at
least 0.1 bitcoin or more in their
wallet and so ultimately what we are
watching is the continued stacking of
sats by those at the lower end of the
ownership so the big whales people who
owned a hundred a thousand ten thousand
bitcoin on chain they continue to
disperse their bitcoin they're selling
into the market and people at the lower
end continue to buy they continue to
stack sats and so ultimately bitcoin is
becoming more and more decentralized the
distribution is getting into more and
more people's hands of on-chain
ownership this is very very important i
think of bitcoin ownership or bitcoin
distribution on chain as one of a
three-legged stool first you want to
have decentralized ownership of the
actual asset two is you wanna have
decentralized mining and three is you
wanna have decentralized node operation
we know that mining has become more and
more decentralized over time after china
banned bitcoin mining in the country we
saw tons of people flood out of inner
mongolia in other regions inside of
china and spread all throughout the
world no longer is 60 of bitcoin mining
hash rate in china instead it is now
much more evenly distributed across the
world it got more decentralized over
time
on top of that we continue to see more
and more bitcoin nodes coming online
there are tens of thousands of bitcoin
nodes all around the world that continue
to pop up and that becomes more and more
decentralized as well so if you go back
and look at that three-legged stool
there's more decentralized ownership
there's more decentralized mining and
there's more decentralized node
operations that tells me that the
network is not only healthy but it
continues to become more and more secure
over time which is exactly what you
would want to see
what did you guys think when you saw
some of these charts in terms of bitcoin
ownership john it's great to see that
more people are acquiring bitcoin and
kind of having the addresses it's really
tough because it's so decentralized that
you can't tell if one individual
actually owns both addresses but
obviously when you have
multiple people coming in and owning
point one bitcoin it's a it's a big deal
right the education has greatly
widespread over the last few months and
years about bitcoin in general and
cryptocurrencies so it's great to see um
i've always kind of worried that one
person owns if one person owns 10
percent of the asset of an asset that's
supposed to be a store value for
everyone it's really tough to uh have
everyone else own it so i like seeing
this stuff like this yeah i think it's
interesting too because the the charts
that you were just showing right if you
look at the accounts that uh the wallets
had owned over ten thousand bitcoin over
a thousand and downward uh they're all
declining from the previous highs right
and they're continuing to say at those
uh those depressed levels that we
previous to the response that we had
seen in october of 2018 or so on so i
think that the accounts in general with
.01 that continue to rise to all-time
highs is a good sign because to your
point it's becoming much more
decentralized than it was previously and
i think that was one of the knocks that
people pointed to earlier on in the uh
kind of in the process of bitcoin
whether it was two three four five or
six years ago was that it wasn't nearly
as decentralized from an ownership
perspective right and if there was only
21 million a lot of this would be
transferred to wealthy people who could
afford to kind of eep into the asset and
buy as much as possible
and what we found is that has continued
to trend downward over time and change
the other piece that i think is
important to call out in this analysis
is that this is not
total um uh kind of data set right what
i mean by that is this is just on chain
bitcoin ownership so there are still
people who own the and purchase via uh
otc desks that buy through exchanges
they have exchange wallets uh they have
software wallets they have hardware
wallets like there's a couple of
different ways that people can own some
of that is counted inside of this uh
on-chain uh distribution some of it is
not and so obviously if you come in and
you buy let's say uh bitcoin on coinbase
or gemini block fi kraken right a whole
multitude of various platforms what you
can see is that you can see that there's
inflows to the exchange
in that wallet but what you can't see is
the breakdown of all of the various
customers so take the largest u.s based
exchange which is coinbase they have you
know about 60 million registered users
or so you cannot see the difference of
who owns what there they know right
because it's their platform but that is
different and and so it makes this
analysis a little bit hard because it's
not just on chain ownership it's also
what's going on in those um
exchanges as well but at least we use
the data set that we have which is the
on-chain ownership and that is
definitely getting more and more uh
decentralized and also more and more
people are stacking sats or kind of
dollar cost averaging into uh what
ultimately will become probably pretty
material uh bitcoin positions i mean the
more decentralized and the more
dispersed the ownership is the better i
think it is for bitcoin you see all
these others and you don't like talk
about the like all coins but when the
guy who created it owns 60 to 70 percent
of the supply
that's a big deal because he can crash
the price if he ever tries to sell
everything that they own or whatever
right so i think the more decentralized
and the more disruptive um or the more
distributed
the ownership bitcoin is the better it
is for the asset yeah i i mean i think
we talk about this health time also but
it's bitcoin and everything else right
bitcoin is the most decentralized
distributed technology from a money
standpoint that's ever been created so i
think uh people need to take these
things and see it as a good thing when
these continue to trend in the right
direction from a decentralization
standpoint because any time the bitcoin
network becomes stronger right more
people are mining uh there's more
wallets with more kind of holding
individual amounts of bitcoin relative
to one big holder i think that's a good
thing
the piece that uh i think folks forget
about this is it's a security mechanism
having decentralized ownership is is
very much a uh benefit or an advantage
from a security standpoint it's not just
about oh all of these other people get
economic empowerment that is important
right and the more people who get access
to sound money and and can prevent uh
the negative effects of currency
debasement the better
but also
there is a huge piece of the security if
everyone you know if one person owned
all the bitcoin that wouldn't be too
good for uh for bitcoin from a kind of a
single point of failure or that there's
an ability to go after that one person
you can manipulate it right all kinds of
bad stuff bitcoin optimizes for security